hi everyone in this video we'll be
talking about right to protein
metabolism and the transport of
lipoprotein so what comes in our mind
when we hear the term lipoprotein so
it's simply lipid and protein right a
combination of both so inside the
lipoprotein particles there would be
repeats such as cholesterol
triglycerides phospholipids etc also
there would be a protein part such as
Apple lipoproteins a combination of all
of these is the lipoprotein now let me
introduce you to the lipoproteins there
are several types of lipoproteins which
are found in our body and they have
their distinct function and importance
so first lipoprotein that we are going
to talk about is chylomicron then we
will talk about VLDL ideal LDL and HDL
VLDL stands for very low density
lipoprotein whereas IDL stands for
intermediate density lipoprotein LDL is
low density lipoprotein while HDL is
high density lipoprotein when we say
some density of the lipoprotein we means
how much is the protein content or how
much protein is there for example in HDL
the protein content is pretty much it is
way more than the VLDL or very
low-density lipoprotein in order to
understand that we need to understand
what is the composition of these
particles so let's talk about the major
Apple lipoproteins present in these
particles first and then we talked about
the overall composition so chylomicron
has Apple iPod protein a Apple B 48 C
and E whereas VLDL has apolipoprotein B
100 so this is the difference between
VLDL and the kind of micron
it also has apolipoprotein see and
apolipoprotein e now after that in ideal
and LDL we both have a Appleby 100 and
in HDL we have majority of the
lipoproteins but if you go over the
overall constant composition of these
particle we would see that 90% of the
chylomicron is triglyceride actually the
triglyceride composition is very high in
case of VLDL and chylomicron whereas for
LDL the concentration of cholesterol is
very high almost 50% of it
so cholesterol has the highest density
of cholesterol whereas real deal and
chylomicron has the highest proportion
of triglycerides in contrast HDL has
higher proportion of apolipoproteins
almost 40% of it so once we have a
overview of the composition of this
particle let's see how these particles
are synthesized one of their functions
how are they metabolized and what is the
turnover rate so let's begin let's say
we eat a food which is enriched in fats
such as a cheesy burger and it would be
metabolized inside our GI tract right so
in the intestine the fact would be
absorbed in form of my sillies right now
in the intestinal epithelial cell the
substance which would be secreted from
the intestinal epithelial cell is the
chylomicron so intestinal epithelial
cell secretes chylomicron which is
enriched in triglycerides other than
triglyceride it has cholesterol Apple B
48 Apple II and Apple lipoprotein C 2
all of these are the components of
chylomicron right so chylomicrons are
exclusively assembled in the intestinal
mucosal sale and the most important
thing
them is they do have triglyceride but
these triglycerides are coming from our
diet all the triglyceride cholesterol
that it has it is coming from our diet
now triglyceride account for 90% of the
volume of this chylomicrons so these are
the two very important points about
chylomicron so this is the overall
composition of the chylomicron as we
have discussed now we wanted to
understand what is the function of
chylomicron so chylomicron can circulate
inside the bloodstream and eventually it
would encounter in the adipose tissue
now it's job is to deposit the
triglyceride
I mean deposit the fat t acids in the
triglyceride when it encounters adipose
tissue so on the adipose tissue there
would be specific enzymes known as
lipoprotein lipase now one part of the
chylomicron which is apolipoprotein c2
would activate the lipoprotein lipase
now lipoprotein lipase is an
extracellular enzyme that is anchored to
a heparin sulfate on the capillary walls
of many cell types and tissues but
majorly it is found in adipose tissue
and it is very important in terms of
breaking down of triglycerides so the
lipoprotein lipase is activated by a
palapa protein C 2 would be eventually
breaking down that fry as I whistle into
free fatty acids and these free fatty
acids would be stored inside the adipose
tissues so the major function of
lipoprotein lipase is to break down fat
and try as a glycerol and now the fact
is freed right so we can understand the
concentration of triacylglycerol is
reduced in these particle now it is
known as chylomicron remnant okay and it
would be up taken by the liver so now we
talk about another type of lipoprotein
particle which is known as VLDL or very
low density
which is exclusively secreted by the
liver not by the intestine so let's try
to understand how we LDL is synthesized
and secreted so we LDL is generated de
novo inside the liver right in the liver
hepatocytes so let's just zoom in to our
HEPA 2 side and try to understand
so liver hepatocytes input of blue COEs
from the bloodstream
now once glucose enters the liver
hepatocytes it would undergo glycolysis
and it would generate pyruvate
eventually that pyruvate would be
converted to acetyl co a and acetyl co
it would eventually give rise to a TCA
cycle and in to generate ATP in the
electron transport chain
now this acetyl co a can also be
utilized inside the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum reticulum to make cholesterol
so cholesterol biogenesis can takes
place in the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum now other than that the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate which is a
by-product of the glycolysis pathway can
be eventually used to make glycerol and
there would be free fatty acids present
in the cytosol itself so free fatty acid
visceral would make triacylglycerol
whereas cholesterol and phospholipid
would also be packaged inside the Golgi
bodies and ultimately it would generate
a lipoprotein particle right and the
protein part comes from these
apolipoprotein components and from liver
the Applebee 100 is the major eco
lipoprotein on VLDL and it is
synthesized by a specific gene present
in the nucleus okay so the
apolipoprotein be 100 containing v LDL
particles would be now released into the
bloodstream
now VLDL encounters HDL and from HDL
VLDL obtains other apple ipod protein
such as apple ipod protein C 2 and
apolipoprotein e so it is very important
that VLDL interacts with the
circulating HDL now as will really pass
through the circulation it also
encounters the fatty tissues or the
adipose tissues and on the adipose
tissues there would be lipoprotein
lipase so just like we have seen for the
chylomicron the lipoprotein lipase would
break down triglyceride and take it
right so once we LDL is depositing quite
a lot of free fatty acid in that opposed
tissue it would be now
deficient in terms of triglyceride it
would have less amount of triglyceride
so that intermediate compound which has
less amount of triglyceride moderate
amount of cholesterol a little bit
amount of proteins as well is known as
intermediate density lipoprotein notice
that they have reduced in size as well
now this ideal would actually interact
ideal is a very transient species and it
would interact with the HDL or high
density lipoprotein HDL would up take a
lot of triglyceride further from the
ideal and in contrast it would give some
amount of cholesterol and ester fide
cholesterol to the ideal as a result
this transient molecule of ideal would
have high level of cholesterol and it
further lose the triglyceride so it
would have no triglyceride very high
level of cholesterol and it would be now
known as LDL so LDL has very high level
of cholesterol and very low triglyceride
now LDL has several surface components
obviously it would have apolipoprotein C
and E it would have a piper between be
100 but eventually these C and E would
be taken by the HDL or it would be
utilized to activate LPL as a result
what would happen it would be left with
a PO be 100 now how LDL is metabolized
and that's the important question okay
so
LDLs major function is to transport
cholesterol from liver to the peripheral
tissue or otherwise it can return the
cholesterol into the liver so obviously
let's say the LDL particle which was
actually formed by the liver in format
of real deal would be ventually carrying
the cholesterol to the testes or to the
adrenal gland now generated from the
liver the LDL particle will be useful
for the adrenal cortex because the
cholesterol that would be deposited by
the real it would generate several
steroid hormones of adrenal cortex
similarly in case of testes the
cholesterol would be utilized to
generate testosterone so in real
transport cholesterol and it is
absolutely necessary for the body but
there is also a harmful side of LDL LDL
can deposit too much cholesterol in the
artery walls and that is detrimental it
would narrow the space of the arteries
and increase the risk of coronary artery
disease or many other heart disease now
this situation is not only detrimental
and it only block the blood flow but it
would also create a huge amount of
inflammation because these macrophages
or the dendritic cell would secrete
inflammatory cytokine in that region
overall it can create several as the
inflammatory symptoms now I would like
to imagine this phenomena just like a
garbage truck
so LDL particles are like garbage truck
they need to dump their garbage in the
dump yard and the garbage would be
recycled so it will need to dump their
cholesterol in the organ that require
cholesterol and it would be utilized so
no problem with that but the problem
comes when the garbage truck is dumping
their loads beside the highway one
possibility is the highway would be
blocked and there would be problem with
transport similarly for LDL when it
starts to dump the cholesterol on artery
walls it could be detrimental for the
body
it can create inflammation it can create
obstruction in the blood flow and
increase the risk of heart disease so
that was the overview of cholesterol as
a lipoprotein particle so we have a lot
of similarity of cholesterol transport
and cholesterol spatter physiology with
the dump truck now apart from that
cholesterol would be eventually taken by
the liver so in the liver hepatocytes
there are specific receptors against
apple b100 the in real receptors which
would recognize that would be 100
because coalesced the LDL particle has
Apple be 100 and ultimately it would
undergo receptor mediated endocytosis
and it would be up taken by the liver
hepatocytes and it would be recycled as
per demand so definitely the most
important components here is the Apple B
100 and the receptor mediated
endocytosis of LDL particle which
recognized a per beam 100 now we try to
understand about HDL now HDL is the
smallest apple lipoprotein in terms of
size but they have highest density of
apolipoproteins
they have quite a lot of proteins more
than 40% of HDL is protein so they have
room to take triglyceride and
cholesterol so HDL interact with real
deal and LDL and what they do is
exchange triglyceride in cost of apple
lipoproteins so it gives proteins to
VLDL and LDL whereas picks up
triglyceride from these triglycerides
and cholesterol esters from these
species now the HDL is a resolver for
apolipoprotein HDL can uptake under
stiff esterified cholesterol as well as
esterified now HDL
helps in the esterification process of
cholesterol and majorly HDL takes part
in the diversed cholesterol transport so
it's a garbage pickup truck so let's say
even if you have garbage on the side of
the highway and there's a pickup truck
which is picking up the garbage then
it's fine right
so HDL try to a pick excess amount of
cholesterol which is dumped on the
arteries and try to save our body from
risk of cholesterol mediated damages in
our artery
so that is why HDL is also known as good
cholesterol while LDL is known as bad
cholesterol so let's just take a quick
overview that what we learned in this
overall video in this video we have a
clear idea about what are the major
apolipoproteins presenting these
lipoprotein particles right so we have
seen chylomicron contains apple b48 as a
signature apple lipoprotein whereas VLDL
has apple b100 now HDL is very rich with
proteins the composition of all of these
lipoprotein particle are different now
chylomicron and VLDL are very enriched
in try SIV so all whereas LDL is
enriched in cholesterol and HDL is found
to be enriched with proteins and we also
looked at the source from which these
particles are secreted we have seen
chylomicron is secreted from intestine
whereas these veal really ideal angular
particles are generally coming from the
liver
whereas HDL can be secreted from both
liver and the interesting so that goes
over all bird's eye view on this
particular topic but in subsequent
videos we'll be talking about all of
these species in lot more details and
try to understand their characteristics
pathophysiology and there are biological
significance so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you